[Music]
someone has tripped the magical alarms
in the element temple by the time you
and the other monks arrived on the scene
you know you have a disaster on your
hands overnight for young apprentices
broke into the temples inner chamber to
steal the sacred element crystals but
when the alarm went off they panicked
and each of them swallowed the crystal
they held right before they were caught
with no idea how to control the crystals
vast powers they'll soon transform into
uncontrollable elemental spirits in
probably enough the old monk next to you
has seen something similar happened
before he explains you must determine
who ate which crystal and get each into
the proper containment field before they
transform the elements compel their
masters those who ate the earth and
water crystals must speak the truth
while those who consumed fire and air
must lie the youths are too scared to
confess their own transgressions instead
they fall to accusing each other
Riku took the water crystal soomi blurts
out Riku interrupts angrily it was Bella
she stole the fire crystal
so Bella yells Jonah ate the air crystal
I saw him
Jonah looks up timidly and shakes his
head I I don't know what happened but
Sumi doesn't have the earth crystal so
who ate which crystal
there's no getting around it this will
take some trial and error but that's not
a bad thing if we make a wrong guess
we'll eventually reach a point where our
conclusions contradict each other that
would allow us to confirm that our
initial guess was wrong and work from
there this is a technique known as proof
by contradiction the trick is in being
strategic about where we begin our
guessing some assumptions might not lead
to contradictions without making further
assumptions we want to pick one that
creates the most constraints on its own
and thus gives us the most information
when it turns out to be right or wrong
take for example Sumi's statement if we
assume she's telling the truth we'd know
the identity of both truth tellers Riku
would have the water crystal and since
she's not lying about him Sumi would
have earth so Bella would have the fire
crystal has Riku says but then Bella
would have to be lying about Jonah
having the air crystal and yet that's
the only remaining option this is a
contradiction and it tells us our
initial assumption was wrong so now we
can go back to the start but with the
added knowledge that Sumi is lying as a
liar Sumi must have either the fire or
air crystal that means Jonah was telling
the truth about her so he can't have
taken either of those and that means
Bella was lying about him so she must
also have either fire or air since Sumi
was lying Riku can't have taken the
water crystal the only one left who
could have it is Jonah and because we've
already identified the two liars Riku
must have the earth crystal that means
Bella has the fire crystal and Sumi has
air you managed to get them all in the
proper containment fields just as the
crystals magic begins to manifest
compared with the difficult task of
training these kids to control their new
powers figuring out who had which
crystal was elementary if you'd like to
continue to expand your logical toolkit
look no further than brilliant org
brilliant is a problem-solving based
platform and it has over 60
courses in math science and computer
science you can brush up on your
mathematical concepts at every level
play with interactive features and solve
your way through a virtually endless
stockpile of riddles visit brilliant org
slash ted-ed to check it out plus the
first eight hundred thirty three of you
to visit using that link will receive
20% off the annual premium subscription
fee